[Laughter]
[Applause]
i mean
seriously that can't be right here let
me show you
hello internet welcome to film theory
the velma
of youtube channels i'll let you decide
exactly what that means really great
turtleneck sweaters and thick-ripped
glasses today we're taking our first
look at the series that taught us that
monsters are really just greedy people
with access to extremely convincing
rubber masks
scooby-doo a show that sustained itself
as a staple of children's cartoon
programming since
the late 60s i mean think about that a
show your grandparents watched as kids
is still
relevant today next thing you know we're
gonna be seeing a reboot of the
flintstones with bam bam
dabbing and wearing supreme
hopefully not but where scooby fred
velma shaggy and daphne have found their
home lately has been
in the memaverse joining the hallowed
ranks of spongebob shrek
and elon musk and of those memes one in
particular has impressed us with
its power level literally ultra instinct
shaggy now in case you have better
things to do with your time than scour
the internet looking for the meme of the
week
that's too generous meme of the day if
it's lucky comes one that started at the
end of last year
and really took off back in january it
comes from a somewhat unusual scene in
the made for tv movie
scooby-doo legend of the fantasor roll
that beautiful beam footage
just your typical cartoon fight scene
right well
kinda but shaggy's calmed meaner and his
ability to predict his opponent's moves
got
youtuber midya to remix the scene with
some dragon ball super music
opening the floodgates to dozens of
spin-off memes and with that
a new z warrior entered the fray ultra
instinct shaggy fight goku ultra
instinct shaggy holds firm
ultra instinct by the way is a reference
to the latest and strongest
transformation for goku in the dragon
ball series
basically some intergalactic jelly beans
decide to hold a tournament of power
because
no season of dragon ball is complete
without one of those across multiple
universes with all the losers getting
erased so to save his universe deus ex
goku needs to achieve his new level
which unlocks
all the powers that he's ever had access
to before as well as any potential power
he still has dormant it's hard to unlock
it's even harder to master and it comes
complete with a brand new hair color for
our favorite saiyan
white here everyone was making fun of me
with my purple hair long story short
true to dragon ball tradition shaggy
becoming a z warrior prompted all sorts
of speculation and joking about his new
power level
a petition even went around to get him
included into the new mortal kombat game
mortal kombat 11. i mean it didn't
happen but it did prompt this awesome
tweet from serious creator ed boon so
i thought i'd try my best at being a
scouter device today to explore what's
really going on with shaggy how is this
character
60 years into his career been able to
harness this newfound power and what
exactly
is that newfound power can it be
quantified
what is his power level to find out tune
in next time to shaggy
ball z or you can just keep watching
this episode of film theory to start
we'll need to understand the source of
shaggy's powers
you see what makes this meme even more
interesting is the fact that shaggy is
always the scared character he's always
the coward so for him to suddenly become
such a skilled fighter is
unexpected to say the least luckily
legend of the fantasor explains the
transition and uh in case you're
wondering about what a fantasor is
it is literally a phantom dinosaur hey
i can't blame them after 60 years of
people wearing rubber masks you gotta
start stretching for new ideas anyway
while on a standard scooby-doo style
adventure
shaggy finds himself locked in a dark
cupboard filled with monster masks
this sends him into a catatonic state
with the doctor giving him the diagnosis
acute threat avoidance hypertrophy
disorder and he's ordered not to
investigate any more scary mysteries or
even step foot into the mystery machine
he told him not to get into the mystery
machine that's why i repaint it the
mustard machine
so to try and cure shaggy from this
crippling fear the gang decides to try
hypnosis
no it's more like
hypnosis but not the boring
old-fashioned kind of hypnosis
psycholuminescent reprogramming
plr the plr process hypnotizes shaggy so
that when he hears the word bad he
literally becomes fearless until he
hears the word again
and this isn't nearly as unrealistic as
it might first sound you see shaggy
starts out diagnosed with acute threat
avoidance hypertrophy disorder a
disorder that doesn't really
exist but if we break down the meaning
of each of those words we can actually
find some pretty similar real life
issues
acute just means that the symptoms come
on suddenly threat
avoidance is obviously referring to
shaggy's overwhelming fear responses
hypertrophy just means to enlarge so
while cardiac hypertrophy may be
problematic because you have an enlarged
heart muscle hypertrophy would actually
be rather desirable because you got
yourself those gains
son in this case the enlargement that
we're talking about would be of the
threat avoidance area of the brain which
is the amygdala
in real life amygdala hypertrophy is a
real thing it can occur when someone is
suffering the effects of acute stress
disorder similar to
and often a precursor to post-traumatic
stress disorder sufferers of acute
stress disorder find themselves
overreacting to negative stimuli
after some traumatic event just like we
see happen with shaggy after he gets
himself trapped in that monster
closet and believe it or not true to the
movie hypnosis
has actually been shown to help reduce
the effects of acute stress disorder
so it looks like scooby-doo's story here
is actually rooted in some real-life
science
at least way more real-life science than
i ever would have expected but then how
does all this explain him turning into
sun goku
well the ultra instinct fight scene that
started this whole thing happens while
shaggy's in one of those fearless states
in the movie mr hubley makes the point
of saying that his plr
is more powerful than your standard
versions of hypnosis this is completely
different
it's so powerful in fact that it even
reprograms hubley himself later on in
the movie so it seems likely that what
shaggy is undergoing here is a
hypnotically induced
super saiyan-like transformation a
concept that for as absurd as it sounds
once again is unbelievably backed up by
real-world science the soviets back in
the 50s and 60s believed so
strongly in the power of hypnosis that
in the 1956
olympics they had 11 hypnotists come
along with them it
seems ridiculous right until you start
looking at the numbers
the soviets managed to out-metal the
americans that year
98 medals to 74. now obviously this
isn't really a transformation and it's
more
correlation than it is causation
otherwise you would see all countries
bringing all sorts of hypnotists along
with them to the games now the
scientists who've studied hypnosis tend
to conclude that it helps put athletes
into a
flow state a mental state of being fully
immersed in the activity that they're
doing
clearing their mind and putting their
everything into what they're doing
at that very moment the crazy thing
about all of this is that it's almost
identical to how ultra instinct is
described it's how goku
is able to unlock this new
transformation in the first place ultra
instinct requires that the fighter
literally stop thinking stop over
analyzing and
just exist in the moment which is why
users of it are able to react
instantaneously to attacks that are
happening around them
it's also why vegeta with his highly
analytical mind struggles when he tries
to master
ultra instinct form he's over thinking
he can't clear his mind enough to enter
the necessary flow state so does that
make shaggy the scooby-doo god tier
equivalent of goku
well not quite power levels in the
dragon ball series are usually
determined by scouter devices measuring
the amount of key energy that's
possessed by a single character
although this number should
theoretically remain somewhat stable
throughout your lifetime
intensive training natural aging and
form changes such as going super saiyan
can
change your total power levels shaggy is
still bound by his human limitations and
lack of training
though his reaction time certainly is
faster when he's in this quote-unquote
ultra instinct mode he still needs time
to think about how he reacts to attacks
and he's missing out on all of those
really nifty glow effects
[Music]
so what exactly then is his power level
in addition to his fight against the
biker gang
shaggy's other shining moment comes at
the end of the movie when he leaps
across a river
jumping up a set of falling rocks to
reach a hole in the roof
shaggy is now jumping from a falling
rock and gaining a huge amount of
altitude from each jump so not only is
shaggy having to create enough force to
jump from rock to rock but he's also
having to do it before the rock he's on
loses too much of its own altitude user
brandala
on livejournal actually shared a
collection of old scooby-doo comics with
information about all of the characters
and shaggy's height is given
at six foot or 1.822 meters so
using shaggy as a ruler in this shot we
can estimate that shaggy is crossing
about 5.5 meters in the course of about
three seconds
using three separate hops shaggy also
has to at least maintain his altitude
and in fact we see him gaining an
altitude with the subsequent two hops
bouncing over a meter off of each rock
as he waits for the next rock to fall
now consider how this needs to work for
shaggy in a normal force diagram of
jumping the ground isn't moving
so it's exerting a force equal to your
weight accelerated by gravity into the
ground
when you want to jump all you need to do
is exert some extra force downward into
the ground and that propels you
up off of it but now imagine the ground
is
also accelerating downwards at the same
speed just like we see the falling rocks
do
in the scene sure you can still jump off
of them but actually gaining any
additional height is going to be
significantly harder
instead of getting the full equal and
opposite effect of your downward push
you now have to account for the fact
that the rock is
falling as well instead of force equals
mass times acceleration like it would
normally be for any sort of jump now it
becomes force equals mass times
acceleration to account for your jump
plus
mass times gravity to account for the
falling rock
we see shaggy hit four rocks in total
and three that we see a good measure of
his collision time with each of them
takes about two to four frames each
about one to two tenths of a second
so if we factor all of this in along
with shaggy's listed 160 pounds or 72.5
kilogram weight
we find that each single leap that
shaggy is making is going to take an
astonishing
5428 newtons or 1220 pounds of force
now in 2014 zydronus zevicus set a world
deadlift record of 1155 pounds
and shaggy has to beat that three times
in the course of a couple seconds
that is super human levels of strength
not quite the power of flights
but he's getting pretty darn close and
in the dragon ball universe
flight or high jumps are definitely
something that we can use to help
calculate
overall power levels now the dragon ball
encyclopedia di zenshu 7
has an incredibly comprehensive look at
various characters power levels
throughout the series which will in turn
allow us to give some rough comparisons
to ultra instinct shaggy
so let's look at shaggy's power set
shaggy has fast reaction times above
average strength and the ability to
almost fly but
not quite his jumping ability is just
really good and really fast where shaggy
hits his clearest limitation is not
being able to create any sort of energy
or
key-related blasts now looking across
the franchise's history the original
dragon ball series
is the only time that we see this level
of more grounded realistic fighting
before power levels started to grow out
of control during
the 23rd world martial art tournament we
see goku square off against his future
wife
chichi during the course of their
sparring we see her demonstrate many of
the same skills that shaggy uses in the
fantasor movie
fast reflexes and super human jumps but
no
actual flying so according to the
encyclopedia
her power level at the time was 130. the
next power level up that we see from
there is 139 as showcased by jackie chun
aka master roshi in disguise during the
21st world martial arts tournament
here he demonstrates many similar skills
as chichi fast reflexes stronger attacks
than normal
except there is one key difference or
should i say
key difference get it key difference
k-i anyway in jackie chun's battles
against both yamcha
and goku he shows his ability to harness
key
related attacks the yamcha battle in
particular shows why shaggy wouldn't be
able to hold his own in a fight like
this
as such ultra instinct shaggy's power
level is best estimated as
comparable to chi chi's level 130 maybe
just slightly more based on that series
of extreme jumps but we definitely know
that it's going to fall somewhere
between 130
and 139 man i feel like a your movie
sucks review right now well
it's not a 130 but it's also definitely
not a 139 so let's give it a 130
and a half i might change that number
later but that's what we're gonna go
with
now that being said it's worth noting
that all of this is without
shaggy doing any training up until this
point he's just been a hippie who lives
out in a van running away from mysteries
given a little practice with master
roshi in the gang
shaggy could absolutely ascend reaching
higher and higher power levels until
finally he's able to stay just as
useless as the other z fighters on the
sidelines as they watch goku do all the
work hey at least he won't die as much
as krillin so shaggy's power level might
be a bit disappointing
definitely not enough to match goku but
you know where the two
are comparable appetite on that one
shaggy might truly have
goku beats but hey that's just
a theory a film theory
and cuts